[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome to a very special report
on battlefield one you probably already
seen the trailer got mustard gas got
horses it's got red baron's oh my
battlefield is going to world war one we
also the trailer but Mike McCarty you
just ran back from redwood shores where
you saw actual gameplay of this and
you've got a lot more details on what
this game has to offer first things
first what was in the gameplay trailer
we haven't seen and how does it look it
looks awesome and the whole focus of
multiplayer is like that land air and
sea so in the game play we saw they were
cutting between like the pilot of this
like red triplane it looked like the Red
Baron right and they cut back to the
person on the rear gun like shredding
other planes following it because
they're saying that you can actually
like dogfight and whatnot it's all just
it's pretty much they're trying to give
you as many like creative ways to add
that battlefield flavor that they said
but at the same time making use the
world war one environment which it looks
pretty great and what the gameplay also
looked really good what else did you
seen the gameplay what in terms of like
scale I'm sure zones they showed us more
like the planes themselves it looks like
you have a lot of room to move unlike
you know like battlefront which dice
also did they also are shown on foot
combat like some of the Springfield
rifle like a medic coming up on this
like Italian hillside it looked like
someone was down he came up behind this
little rock wall syringe him they cut to
a scout was up on top like the the scope
the shot through the scope the sniper
rifle would look like the maps were huge
like like battlefield you know like
early Battlefield games it it looks like
it's much more expansive and mean they
got how many more months before releases
like this looks like a near-final thing
yeah we'll get into an integrating a
second we have a bunch of stuff to talk
about but just to be a little bit
surface level for a second how did it
look in comparison to the one-minute
sort of in engine trailer we did see it
looked it it looked similar like it I
don't it's not that trailer was not like
facetious at all hmm was the gameplay
trailer do you think like souped up at
all as was it he was pretty genuine
gameplay it looks very genuine I mean it
was definitely like there was a few
shots with her running through smoke and
then people getting mowed down from them
and it looked like it was from the first
person perspective they might have kind
of taken Liberty with that what
look pretty similar vehicles yeah I want
to know all about all rights I just have
to say it's been a long time since I've
been able to like fly with a joystick
right yeah and that is key now you saw
some awesome dog fighting my biggest
concern is that we're gonna have really
simplified controls I mean I'm you know
joystick wise now we're these planes
rolling a lot could you could you see
like a genuine roll and some actual dog
fighting moves so the shots they're
showing from the actual the turrets and
whatnot this plane was like going all
over the place like dogfights they said
they want to actually let you do dog
fights while another one your friends
doing a bombing run to clear the way for
the tanks and the infantry and the other
one is doing a strafing run along the
trench so I can't say that it's I don't
know how it's gonna feel obviously but
they said they're like making sure you
can do all this stuff so because they
want the air combat to feel very air
combat its own thing but also feed into
the navel in the land but they don't
want to strip down anyone to just like
make them all fit together what other
types of vehicles did you see we heard
him talk about horses time jack well I
guess were in world war one kind of yeah
the like Battle of the Marne what's not
the first time they had like Britain had
tanks whatever I think I'm probably
mistaken but I'm yeah they had these
like the tanks they showed this one part
of the guy walked up from the trench
these tanks were rolling toward him they
said they're gonna have light tanks
heavy tanks armored trucks they're gonna
have battleships you can control the
battleships according to Danny Berlin's
lead designer he was saying you can
demolish a shoreline with the ship with
the battleships and there will be like
lighter cruisers I imagine just to you
know kind of like add that inter naval
battles I guess to like between navies
not just like bombarding horses which
will function like hair inside like as
motorcycles i think more like to scout
and flank did they say you could fight
on the horses are under there i wouldn t
supply i wouldn't be surprised because
was a lot of the melee combat system
right sure they said that they built
like a completely new maybe not
completely new but they designed this
specifically to help you do there's a
bayonet charge ability you can use your
like trowel shovels you can use that
trench club that like spike thing that
the guy in the cover has as well as
sabers the guy in the horse they kept
showing how to say Bria I imagine they
showed that because like maybe
you know like you can do that like Zelda
cool did you get a sense so it seems
like we have our classic assault medic
recon support classic Scout yeah yeah
Scout did you get in the impression of
like how they work in this combined arms
environments is it any different from
previous Battlefield games does it feel
the same with but with a different
flavor it feels the way they described
it sounds pretty traditional so support
sounds like it's the class it's going to
have the heavy machine guns in this case
like the water-cooled dirty Cal's I
imagine they had another one where the
drum was on top of it but it seems like
yeah Scout is going to be it seems
pretty traditional as far as they're
doing it they didn't mention like what
kind of progression there will be in
terms of like our overarching RPG
umbrella or anything um he's going to be
talking about 64 players in the
multiplayer battles mom and to ranch
really quickly in a single player this
campaign they said is gonna it's
featured I like a multifarious group
that's like experiencing a changing
world I don't know it's some PR line but
they said they're trying to make it more
like a battlefield campaign as opposed
to the last like three games have been
trying to go like Call of Duty ish it's
gonna be open um I would imagine that as
massive as the 64 player multiplayer
arenas but maybe like my company little
bit right that's what I was thinking
some like little bit more open or like
those some of those halo missions where
you can go do different objectives at
certain points but they said they want
to have that same land air sea combat
it's in the multiplier in the campaign
that's what they were missing for so
right what about there was a brief sort
of leak this morning where we saw a
Harlem Hellfighters and on what now
looks like the boxart actually did they
talk about any specific spent
single-payer that way so rob crossley
over the UK saw a trailer same times me
he interviewed different people and he
was saying are they were saying that
originally the leaks i was like an
alternate history World War one it seems
like they're pretty rooted in history
I'm sure they're gonna take liberties to
make it more fun but it seems like
they're going mean the Harlem
Hellfighters between that like the Red
Baron playing the they're trying to
focus more on battles that not everybody
knows about snot just gonna be like Vic
Dolan and Mar and yeah you know though
it's gonna be like Italian Alps of the
deserts of Arabia I mean it's a massive
war that gets overshadow all the time by
world war two and they really want to
kind of make you that era um but yeah
they didn't really say too much about
single-player they said they're going to
talk about that more but I kept asking
questions I couldn't did you get the
impression I've
think what a lot of people here world
war one they think both action spring
fails and you know like how are they
gonna how they going to make that
setting exciting for battlefield players
who've come to expect a large variety of
weapons and also like customization of
their weapons which there wasn't a lot
of in world war one right i don't know
about customization and again that might
factor into like the progressions just
so much they didn't talk about for
multiplayer if they have one I imagine
they will is some customization alright
with the weapons I'm not they said like
I don't know like how you I imagine you
could yeah because I mean different like
scopes and whatnot for like bolt-action
rifles because they showed like them
actually like they showed like a
documentary showing them shooting actual
rifles they're switching to stuff but
they said like a common misconception
World War one is that it's all like
Springfield bolt action and then maybe a
trench shotgun and a 30 Cal mashina but
they're like they said no there's going
to be automatic rifles semi-automatic
rifles revolvers semi-automatic handguns
there's going to be different kinds of
machine guns because it like it's all
these different armies and all these
different nations and these factions are
gonna make use of all of them so it's
not just gonna be both action all the
time can I put red tiger stripe skin cuz
i need to know at least a little cheetah
skin or some like that i hope so no idea
only 200 $19 yeah i hope not that'd be
really funny to look at like textbooks
to see Rob great great grand Dadd with a
zebra-skin rifle I have one question on
there was some screenshots we saw of
like the dot I have to go back and
dogfight it looked like there were a lot
of planes in the air I know there's also
a blimp which want to get to but did you
see a lot of planes flying around so
from the gameplay they showed us the
brief one there at least like four other
planes in the sky was chasing them but
the screenshots I unless they're
misleading it shows like six or seven
eight frames in the sky what about
Soviet last shot of the trailer is a
freaking blimp yeah you know anything
about that thing so rob crossley kept
asking them if you can pilot it or go
inside it at all maybe but I don't they
haven't told me anything and that they
didn't tell anything in the gameplay the
gameplay itself ended the same way the
game plays showed the planes going
around the blimp so I it definitely does
not look like it's part of the skybox
just for appearances sake like
battlefront it's their looks I would be
very surprised if you can't in
activate in some way because you can use
battleships why would you bill uses up
right sure to be fair the battleships
seem to be a lot more like that ac-130 s
from previous battle fields where you
wreck shop and then people figure out
what you're doing and they come after
you and shut you down pretty fast okay
we talked about his classes we're
talking with vehicles talked about
weapons talk about single-player and
multiplayer is ni goes the sort of we
haven't touched on or what is your story
overall impression of it from talking to
developers actually seeing gameplay I
think we covered all my overall reaction
today was very pleasantly surprised I
was going into it just kind of expecting
maybe like a future warfare thing or
just another like battlefield five
military shooter but it's a military
shooter but like a very different era
that we haven't seen in games I'm sure
there are games World War one but
nothing like triple a budget all right
coming in october 21st for everyone it's
october 18th on EA access that's only
for pc and xbox one right correct yeah
alright so ps4 is 21st got weight around
and I'm sure we'll have much more
information on it over the next couple
of months as well thank you so much for
watching this special report I'm
battlefield one if you've any thoughts
about the game and your expectations for
what you like and what you did like to
please put it in the comments below
thanks very much
Ronnie Beck
you